الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قالب
الدنيا في الواقع وعلى المنصات بسبب هجوم
عنيف شنوا على راند سانتوس حاكم فلوريدا
من نفس حزبه على فكره يعني لكن في اخبار
انه خلاص الان بيستعد لسانطس لاعلان ترشحه
للرئاسه وبالتالي حيكون منافس
اوكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني
لانه في 2018 ترامب اي الترشح ديسانس
لمنصب حاكم وبالتالي ترشح للرئاسه الان
خيانه تصريحات في تجمع انتخابي في ايرون
عشره دقائق نازل لكن يبدو هذه العشره
دقايق برضو ما شافت غليله لانه في الطياره
وهو راجع من هناك سالو صحفيين بعد الكلام
اللي قالوا اذا هو كمان ندمان انه دعم
يكون حاكم فلوريدا في 2018 وتربق لهم نعم
ندمان وقال لهم نصا كان ميت مثل الكلب
والله لترامب قال انه ديصانتيس كان كلب
ميت كان سياسي ميت ولولا دعمي له ما كان
صار شيء وكان زمانه الان بيشتغل في شركه
محاماه او بيعمل اي شيء تاني وما حد داري
عنه
[موسيقى]